[Music]
the initial generation of the primary
genetic sequence of a particular
organism
is called de novo sequencing a detailed
genetic analysis of any organism is
possible only after de novo sequencing
has been performed
de novo sequencing is typically
accomplished by assembling individual
sequence reads into longer contiguous
sequences
or correctly ordered context in the
absence of a reference sequence
historically de novo sequencing was
carried out using capillary
electrophoresis sequencers
with its long read lengths and high
accuracy ce-based sequencing made
overlap consensus assembly the gold
standard technology for de novo projects
however more recently the high
throughput capabilities of massively
parallel sequencing
and the development of short-read
assemblers have significantly reduced
the time and cost associated with
sequencing an entire genome
during the de novo assembly process
partially or sometimes fully overlapping
reeds are assembled into one or more
contigs
sets of overlapping or non-overlapping
contacts are joined into one or more
scaffolds
sets of overlapping or non-overlapping
scaffolds are joined into a single
chromosome
in the contiguous assembly step reeds
must overlap by a minimum number of base
pairs
or k-mers before they can be mapped
together
in the scaffold assembly step contigs do
not necessarily have to overlap in order
to be joined together
this can be attributed to paired in
sequencing
in the chromosome assembly step
scaffolds are joined together in a gap
filling
gap closing or genome finishing process
this final step is difficult and
sometimes impossible to complete using
only short read technology
the presence of repetitive sequences
especially can inhibit gap filling using
only short
reads although some progress is being
made in this area
finishing complete chromosomes often
require the use of multiple sequencing
technologies and hybrid assembly
protocols
it is common to see short read
technology combined with long read
technology to generate fully finished
genomes
employing multiple sequencing
technologies on a per sample basis can
be costly
there are many de novo assembly
algorithms and software applications
available
for next generation sequencing projects
for small genome assembly such as
bacterial scale genomes
tools such as spades ingenius can be
useful
the major factors that determine the
required depth in a de novo genome
sequencing study
are the error rate of the sequencing
method the assembly algorithms used
the repeat complexity of the particular
genome under study and the read length
genomes that have been sequenced to high
depths by short read technologies are
not necessarily a substantial
improvement
in assembly quality compared with those
produced using the earlier lower
coverage sanger sequencing technology
although the human genome was initially
assembled to high quality with eight
tenfold coverage using long read sanger
sequencing
a raw coverage of approximately 73 fold
was required to generate the first short
read-only assembly of the giant panda
genome that was of lower quality than
the human genome
a similarly low coverage approximately
7.5 full dog genome
which is similar in size to that of the
giant panda and was assembled using
sanger sequencing reeds
is more complete and more contiguous
than the giant panda genome
these differences arise because sanger
sequencing reads are longer
are derived from larger insert libraries
and can be assembled using mature
assembly algorithms
high quality assemblies are now often
produced using hybrid approaches
in which the advantages of high depth
short read sequencing are complemented
with those of lower depth
but longer read sequencing in general
low coverage has two principal effects
on analyses and biological
interpretation
first it is not possible to resolve
whether in absence of a protein coding
gene
or a disruption of its open reading
frame represents a deficiency of the
assembly or a real evolutionary gene
loss
second and perhaps more seriously low
depth can introduce sequence errors
that are in danger of being mistakenly
propagated through downstream analyses
and misdirecting conclusions of a study
to mitigate this possibility two
approaches are recommended
first low-quality bases or sequences
that align poorly against a closely
related genome should be discarded from
such analyses
second adjacent bases that have high
quality scores should also be discarded
because they can contain a high density
of residual sequence errors